foreign
[Music]
for Tuesday October 18th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
if you live in California you might have
seen this commercial featuring Governor
Gavin Newsom fellow Californians I need
to warn you about proposition 30. one
company cynical scheme to grab a huge
taxpayer-funded subsidy the company the
governor is talking about is the ride
hailing giant lift and the ballot
measure that Lyft supports proposition
30 would raise taxes on high income
residents specifically an additional
1.75 tax on income over 2 million
dollars for the next 20 years that would
then be used to fund the transition to
Greener forms of transportation as well
as fund Wildfire prevention and lift and
prop 30's other supporters are running
ads too California has the worst air
pollution in the country
the top two causes are vehicles and
wildfires prop 30 helps clean our air
now the positions the two sides are
taking might seem a bit strange Governor
Newsom has supported some of the
strictest environmental laws in the
country and Lyft is a big corporation
whose business relies on driving so
what's behind this strange Division and
what will it mean for the ballot
measures chances
joining us to discuss that is our Tech
reporter pritik Arana hi pritika thanks
for joining us Hey Zoe it's great to be
back on the show so can you start us off
by you know telling us why Lyft says
it's supporting this ballot measure prop
30. right so you know lyft's co-founder
and CEO Logan green wrote quite a
compelling blog post last month
explaining why the company was
supporting the measure and he says that
as a father of four what he sees in
California really bothers him and he
says he sees record setting wildfires
plaguing every part of the state
unrelenting drought extreme heat and he
says we urgently need to save the
environment so that's what Liv's
co-founder says but if you take a closer
look analysts say the real reason Lyft
is in this is because California
requires them to convert most of their
vehicles to zero emission vehicle goals
meaning go electric by 2030 and that is
a tall order remember Lyft doesn't own
any of the cars the people driving on
their platform are gig workers so in
order to you know Force these people to
go electric they would need to
incentivize drivers make it cheaper for
drivers who typically tend to be lower
and middle income earners to afford
electric vehicles they would need to
have Chargers across California to make
it easier for these drivers to actually
sustain that shift okay so that's what's
behind maybe lyft's thinking Governor
Gavin Newsom who has been you know a big
supporter of green energy measures in
the past he does not support this ballot
measure can you tell us a little bit
about why he doesn't and why is he so
cynical about lyft's support of it yeah
covered in Newsome surprised many in the
state it when he came out in these ads
and he basically slammed Lyft for
bankrolling this measure now to be clear
both camps support the switch to going
green and they both say we need to do
more to prevent wildfires we need to do
more to reduce carbon emissions we need
to do more to switch to Greener forms of
transportation so both groups agree with
this where they disagree is who should
pay for it now Governor newsom's
argument is that we don't need extra
taxes for something that we're already
doing he says that he has committed 10
billion dollars over the next six years
to build charging stations across the
state to incentivize people to switch to
electric vehicles so we don't actually
need to raise the tax rate which by the
way is already high in California Lyft
says it's a good thing that Governor
Newsom is thinking about this and has a
plan in place but 10 billion over 6
years isn't enough for long-term and
sustainable shift what Lyft and other
environmentalists are proposing is to
collect about 100 billion over the next
20 years and use that money for the long
haul you know this isn't just a fight
between Lyft and Newsome though I mean
who are the other supporters and
opponents of this bill yeah you know
it's brought together
a very unusual set of characters people
who typically wouldn't work with each
other have joined forces so on one side
we have Governor Newsom who's a Democrat
joining with the state's most powerful
teachers union and we also have business
groups and the California Republican
party that is opposing the tax so
Governor Newsom is on the same side as
you know his sworn enemy the Republican
party on the other side we have Governor
newsom's Democratic party
environmentalists and Union groups that
are standing with Lyft so it's been
interesting to see the divisions that
this measure has created what about Uber
where does it stand on this issue
because I imagine it would have some of
the same concerns as Lyft oh absolutely
you know if more money is spent on
incentivizing drivers to switch to
electric vehicles if more money is spent
on charging station
Uber absolutely benefits as well but
they've kind of been silent on this
proposition they haven't joined forces
with Lyft because Lyft has more to lose
their exposure to California is way
greater than Ubers just to give you an
example some 16 of lifts bookings come
from California versus nine percent for
Uber so you can really see that Lyft is
doubling down because even though
California is important for both big
ride share companies it's way more
important for Lyft what kind of money is
backing the campaigns so this is again a
very interesting one the yes Camp which
is environmentalists and Lyft they've
raised about 50 million dollars to
support the measure and what's
interesting is that almost all of that
money has come from Lyft so Lyft has
basically bankrupt rolled more than 95
percent of this campaign on the other
side the opponents have raised just
about 20 million compared to the yes
camps 50 million and that side is being
funded by the California Teachers
Association and a few Silicon Valley
investors and billionaires so some
notable names include Netflix CEO read
Hastings Silicon Valley investor Sam
Altman and another investor and a
partner at Sequoia Capital Michael
Moritz okay so that's all the money
that's all the people who are backing
these kinds of things what are the polls
saying about the chances of this ballot
measure passing you know before Governor
Newsom jumped into The Fray with his
television campaign that was
overwhelming support for this measure so
in July a poll said 63 percent of
Californians were in favor of the
measure in September another poll said
55 percent were in support and just
weeks after Governor newsom's ads began
to run in October we're seeing support
dip below 50 for the first time so now
only 49 of Californians are supporting
this measure so it's going to be a very
close race I guess we'll just have to
watch on Election Day that's a reporter
pritik Arana thanks for joining us thank
you Zoe and that's it for today's Tech
news briefing if you want more Tech
stories check out our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]